os guen difficile de faire plus breton
comme n'ont pourtant le nouveau patron
la droite parisienne est né à toulon
c'est ainsi l'homme aime bien brouiller
les repères issu de l'udf puis de
démocratie libérale c'est un chiraquien
de toujours conseiller de paris en 83 et
les maires adjoints en 89
une collaboration avec jacques chirac
qui se poursuit comme ministre de la
fonction publique en 95 maire du xvième
arrondissement il a trouvé son fief
réélu dès le premier tour aux dernières
élections législatives
bien entendu je n'ai pas l'habitude de
perturber les vrais les délibérations du
conseil mais je voudrais vous dire trop
modeste car depuis un an et demi c'est
quand même lui l'opposant le plus
virulent à bertrand delanoë
vous avez dit hier il s'est imposé comme
le synthétiseur de toutes les tendances
de la droite avec le soutien de jacques
chirac et d'alain juppé je n'ai pas la
grosse tête
je ne suis pas le candidat virtuel à la
mairie de paris dans cinq ans les choses
se présenteront tout à fait autrement
mais il est déjà sur une rampe de
lancement et bétonne ses alliances
il a nommé comme vice président philippe
goujon possible futur secrétaire de la
fédération ump de paris
nous souhaitons véritablement expliqué
au parisien de l'est qui ont voté pour
la gauche
à quel point les promesses de delanoë ne
sont que des promesses
seul bémol à cette nouvelle voir le
président du groupe n'était lui que pour
deux ans
[Musique]